[Música]
ou a não sei se você é forte
eu não sei se você é suficiente e é uma
coisa tão pequena que eu devia ser maior
do que essa coisa coisa eu não consigo
nem falar em voz alta
às vezes eu olho para a janela e ela
parece à luz da festa embaixo da porta
uma manhã escura tão convidativa
antes de sair do quarto parece que o dia
vai ser tão bom então eu não saio eu me
deito me apego a esses escuro
eu olho para a janela e ela parece à luz
na festa embaixo da porta tão
convidativa
talvez eu decepcionei vocês aqui hoje
porque quando a gente fala de hiv
a expectativa é ouvir uma história muito
triste uma história de abandono uma
história horrorosa que nem a dos filmes
e aí eu entro que andando e talvez vocês
esperassem que eu entrasse numa cadeira
de rodas com o soro do lado muito pálido
cheio de manchas na pele e pô
entrou um rapaz bonitinho minha mãe só
faz a palestra repara não
mas deixa eu explicar para vocês porque
eu tô aqui assim saudável
eu recebi o diagnóstico de hiv em 2010
na época eu tinha 18 anos
eu estava começando a minha vida tinha
passado na faculdade tirar a carta de
motorista tinha conhecido um rapaz
estava namorando ele conhecia minha
família conhecer meus amigos a gente
viajar junto e aí me ligaram do
laboratório gabriel
você precisa vir aqui buscar o resultado
de um exame pessoalmente e ronan recebeu
o diagnóstico naquela época me colocou
no lugar que talvez muitos de vocês
ainda estejam eu tinha certeza que o hiv
ea aids e aids e levar à morte em pouco
tempo sem nenhuma dignidade no meio do
caminho mas a realidade foi bem
diferente
eu cheguei em casa chorando a minha mãe
me colocou no colo dela e já foi marcar
consulta do médico ela meu pai e minha
irmã sempre me apoiaram minha irmã
acabou de ser aceita trabalhando no
fundo global para hiv e tuberculose
malária
ela fez o trabalho dela meu namorado com
quem eu conversei na mesma noite estava
super assustado virou pra mim e disse
vai ficar tudo bem e eu não lembro de
nenhum amigo que tenha se afastado por
causa disso alguns se assustaram porque
eles não entendiam que eu ainda podia
ter saúde uma vida plena
mas aí quando alguém entende alguma
coisa a gente explica e repete repete de
outro jeitinho até que uma hora as
pessoas aprendem então desculpa
decepcionar mas eu tinha que vir aqui
porque nós somos 800 mil pessoas vivendo
com hiv no brasil e embora existam
algumas que estão melhores do que eu
existem muitas que estão piores
esse texto que eu falei no início da
minha peça e é baseado na realidade um
rapaz que me mandava mensagens 3 horas
da manhã dizendo que estava pensando em
colar da janela eu acordava às 8 e não
sabia se ele tinha pulado naquele dia eu
precisava vir representar essa
comunidade
só que aí fica difícil para mim falar de
hiv porque a expectativa que vocês
tenham um monte de slide duas genitálias
com corrimento
e aí eu ia mostrar os gráficos de barras
com os números bem impressionantes e não
me aprofundar muito neles que era só pra
dar medo mesmo ea repetir
use camisinha use camisinha use
camisinha
então a gente não vai falar de hiv
porque não quero decepcionar
eu não trouxe gráficos e não trouxe
falta não sei mexer no powerpoint e eu
não conhecia o pavor não conhecia o medo
da aids como a geração anterior conheceu
eu não posso falar desse medo da aids
com propriedade e eu não quero é só isso
então acabou
boa sorte eu acho que sim porque se eu
fosse falar de hiv para atender às
expectativas de vocês eu tinha que falar
da minha família me botando pra fora
apontando pro filho gay dizendo eu
avisei
era nisso que é darci estava procurando
e ao invés disso eu guardo até hoje um
bilhete da minha mãe na noite que eu fui
conversar com o meu namorado e ela dizia
a qualquer hora o nosso colo está sempre
disponível para saber que naquela casa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
eles falaram que podia chorar e eu
sacaneei falando que vai ser aqui e eu
sempre soube que ia ser acolhido
independente de qualquer coisa naquela
casa
eu podia falar dos exames no início que
são muito assustadores porque são muitos
mas a lembrança que eu tenho um médico
super diz passado que minha mãe arranjou
enquanto um monte de piada
superdivertido explicando cara a gente
está só fazendo um checkup a gente quer
saber como é que o corpo está antes do
tratamento para poder fazer o
comparativo depois não significa que
esteja em perigo
eu podia falar dos efeitos colaterais
que existiram a tontura um calorão que
subir na cabeça a vontade de bater em
todo mundo
os pesadelos mas nas primeiras noites
que eu também remédio meu namorado
dormiu comigo e essa lembrança que eu
tenho dele vigilante pronto pra minha
para casa alguma coisa acontecesse e não
aconteceu aí eu fiquei solteira e você
deve pensar sim por encontram os babacas
no caminho agora vem no peso do negócio
e encontrei mas eu encontrar gente
babaca com hiv ou seja vai ver
e fora isso eu tive um processo de
redescoberta sexual muito bacana com os
parceiros que respeitaram muito de
entender o que significa a se relacionar
sexualmente agora que eu tinha hiv
e aí eu tinha uma esperança do trabalho
porque eu trabalhava com criança
mas a diretora da escola virou pra mim e
falou assim qualquer coisa a gente faz
uma reunião que achar ruim vai embora
procurou a escola é muita gente incrível
na minha vida
e aí eu saí do armário o segundo armador
fez uma postagem no facebook falando que
eu vivia com o hiv e facebook a terra de
ninguém então provavelmente chegou um
monte de de comentário maldoso né não
o que veio daí foi um projeto que eu
carrego há quase dois anos sobre saúde
sexual através da arte da informação e
do acolhimento
então tudo que eu posso fazer é que ele
tava lá está alguns privilégios que me
fizeram viver bem com hiv e poder
trabalhar a partir do hiv uma família
amorosa um médico atencioso parceiros
respeitosos amigos preocupados uma chef
leal
mas calma privilégio e uma honra
isso é básico isso é essencial como é
que a gente chegou nesse ponto em que
tem uma família que te apoia é
privilégio como é que a gente chegou
nesse lugar em que a melhor qualidade
que o namorado namorada podem ter de
respeitar como que um médico atencioso é
diferente dos demais
isso tudo deve ser pré requisito como é
que um grupo de pessoas se junta e disso
uma família
se eles não estão dispostos a acolher o
outro independente do que aconteça como
é que a gente estabelece parceria se não
tem um respeito mútuo
como é que uma pessoa passa anos numa
faculdade de medicina residência estudar
pra caramba e chega no consultório abri
a porta e vi um saco de órgãos e não uma
pessoa
nada disso é privilégio a gente não pode
perder essa perspectiva é tudo básico é
tudo essencial respeito é fundamental
carinho é fundamental
amor é uma coisa que não dá pra viver
sem nada disso deveria ser considerado
boa sorte
então não vou falar da doença porque eu
não conheci da aids a não ser pelos
livros pelos filmes os casos que os
relatar e eu não quero conhecer hoje a
gente tem tecnologia para todas as
pessoas que vivem com hiv não conhecerem
a aids
o problema está no acesso à saúde no
preconceito no medo
então não vou falar disso não vou falar
da doença eu quero falar sobre carinho
porque falar sobre hiv hiv através do
medo é muito fácil as fotos lembra as
fotos em preto e branco a galera magra
morrer no hospital
as genitálias flutuando por aí usa
camisinha usa camisinha usa camisinha
só que isso não é suficiente e medo e
sexo são duas coisas que não têm nada a
ver esse medo do sexo da rejeição de no
ptc o universo do outro isso silencia e
se distancia e antt coloca a culpa no
tesão
à época ela na hora estava com tesão no
centro e pá que tesão é esse que você
esquece que na sua frente tem uma pessoa
não é só alguns buracos que você pode
revezar não como é que se esquece que é
que não é um corpo que afeta e é capaz
de ser afetado é um corpo que está
suscetível ao que há de melhor e de pior
nesse mundo
essa objetificação é justamente o que
impede a prevenção a gente precisa falar
sobre essas coisas para promover o
respeito essa prevenção do medo que a
gente vê muito por aí durou pouco e os
especialistas ea mídia adoram se
esquivar dessa realidade
na década de 80 e 90 o que foi
importante fez um monte de gente que
nunca usou camisinha passar a usar
porque naquela época você usava
camisinha saindo com gente estranha por
aí você tá saindo com uma moça de
família porque está usando camisinha não
é namoro sério vocês não vão casar
e aí vem uma nova geração que não
conhece o pavor da aids como a geração
anterior e por isso não se relaciona com
esse processo da mesma maneira que a
gente faz então a gente torce para as
pessoas voltarem a morrer de aids
a gente fica esperando essas pessoas
perderam a dignidade
a gente explora a tristeza eo abandono
por qual muitas delas passam para fazer
grandes campanhas nacionais
se alguém é que acha que é correto sob
bate que vocês me ofender - pode subir
mesmo espera o pessoal de cima se quiser
descer para saber o nosso tratamentos
remédios que a gente toma todo dia o
estigma com a gente está sujeito a
solidão que muitos de nós enfrentamos
nada disso está à venda para as agências
publicitárias é o nosso processo é a
nossa jornada
já o carinho é patrimônio da humanidade
o carinho aí para quem quiser pegar quem
quiser dividir compartilhar
a multiplicar ele é de todos nós e o
caminho do carinho é diferente do medo a
gente tem que aproveitar essa ausência
do medo e desenvolver uma nova
estratégia de prevenção uma estratégia
através do carinho que tem muito mais a
ver com o momento global que a gente
vive agora quer de respeitar e valorizar
as diversidades independente de quantos
movimento surjam contra isso
o cargo exige trabalho muito mas ele
vale a pena porque a mudança provocada
pelo carinho é uma busca uma mudança na
base é fundamental o respeito porque
carinho significa conexão e para fazer
uma conexão que você e eu preciso tirar
as barreiras do caminho eu preciso tirar
o estigma o preconceito eu preciso
acabar com a discriminação
a gente só vai ter carinho se a gente
combater a desinformação exemplo ótimo
disso a melhor forma de combater o hiv e
hoje é combater o machismo
se a gente começa a discutir essa hétero
normatização do sexo e se falou
centrismo em que o feminino é só um
complemento do sexo masculino e um do
sexo masculino que vai decidir sobre a
prevenção a despeito do que sua parceria
acha que eu falo parceria porque o homem
no relacionamento homoafetivo também
assume papéis que para a sociedade vão
ser tidos como femininos
aí vem a homofobia tudo isso anda junto
e tudo isso atrapalha a prevenção o
acesso à saúde todas essas agressões
esse diálogo precisa acontecer porque o
medo se instalar na infertilidade do
silêncio
já o carinho ele vai andar junto da
informação são duas coisas que não se
separam
se eu te compreendo eu vou te amar e se
eu te amo eu vou querer te entender cada
vez mais jovem não falar em empatia
empate é isso essa espiral do carinho
ela é alimentada pela informação
já o medo alimento silêncio e não houve
de volta nenhuma obrigado a gente
ficando vazio na ignorância onde o
carinho se instalar
verdadeiramente a gente vai ter a quebra
do silêncio o fim da reclusão ninguém
vai precisar mais se esconder
eu não estou falando só de quem vive com
hiv
mas de qualquer vulnerabilidade qualquer
condição estigmatizada doura vai poder
ser debatida vai poder ser mostrada
vista a gente não precisa esperar
conhecer alguém com hiv para aprender
sobre isso aprender que quem está em
tratamento para hiv e direitinho não
transmite o vírus aprender que no caso
de um acidente ou inclusive de uma
violência sexual
você tem um tratamento de 28 dias que
vai impedir a infecção pelo hiv
aprendi que a gente pode ter filho como
qualquer outra pessoa
filhos que vão crescer sem exames sem
remédios sem o vírus
a gente tem que se preparar agora e sai
gritando pra eu falo sobre eu falo sobre
carinho empatia eu falo sobre hiv e eu
não quero mais falar sobre a aids porque
eu entendo que o hiv não é só uma
questão biomédica a questão biomédica
evoluiu pra caramba eu quero falar da
questão social
eu falo sobre uma educação que paute
relacionamentos não o sexo biológico
higienizado um desenho de duas
genitálias ainda são cortadas pelo meio
e aí a gente não entende que os
adolescentes vão pra cama e não vem nada
do que eles encontrarão no livro estava
esperando um desenho em 2d cortado no
meio não é isso mesmo não eu falo sobre
relacionamentos e são todos os curtos os
longos os sérios e os casuais
nunca nunca nunca nunca nunca vai ser só
sexo sempre vai ter outras repercussões
do que só um momento de prazer eu falo
sobre saúde
eu não falo sobre doença a doença a
gente quer curar a doença a gente quer
que acabe mas falar de saúde é pra
sempre tratar a doença é só uma medida
provisória falar sobre esses e outros
assuntos que cria espaços seguros
no caso do hiv quando a gente fala sobre
isso vocês passam a entender que eu
tenho horário para tomar remédio eu tomo
todo dia e me olhar torto
vocês entendem que às vezes vou faltar
uma aula um trabalho que eu tenho uma
consulta interna que dá um frio na
barriga que eu não vou nunca poderia
explicar para vocês quando eu conheço
alguém porque em algum momento
a vontade de contar sobre isso e assim
complicadinho entende eu quero me
entregar por inteiro assim não precisa
falar não precisa mas é um desejo eu
quero ter o direito de ter essa vontade
de entregar por inteiro de me relacionar
completamente e dá um aperto se a gente
se corta sem querer ver o próprio sangue
mesmo sabendo que ele é inofensivo
porque ele é testemunha dessa infecção e
aí se você compreende você quer pra cima
isso minha mãe se chama só que eu tomar
remédio todo o dia principalmente no
começo do tratamento que eu estava com a
cabeça pra nada foi importante pra
caramba a um médico que quando eu
entrava cabisbaixo sorrir pra mim e
queria saber da minha vida porque
entendia que não era só aqueles exames
alguém que olha pra você e diz vai ficar
tudo bem que o silêncio não vai embora
sozinho
não adianta eu falar e do lado aí vocês
escutarem a gente não quer esses gritos
isolados esses ruivos de dor acontece o
técnico depois o saquinho assim acaba a
gente quer caminhar junto
isso aqui é só o começo eu fiz um
compromisso de sempre que alguém
estivesse disposto a ouvir falar sobre e
sempre que alguém quiser falar sobre eu
estar disposto a ouvir
é um compromisso que eu levo muito a
sério e vocês podem fazer também
chegando em casa e compartilhando sobre
as palestras estão assistindo aqui hoje
e nos amigos que não conseguir a
inscrição e passando inveja falando isso
e aquilo
e aí quando sai na internet vocês
compartilham a gente não pode deixar o
silêncio chegar nem por um instante
vamos criar espaços seguros
vamos falar sobre vamos juntos
ainda terá valor
hayatou seu celular para fazer o inep
muito obrigado gente boa noite cabe me
senti que a torcida vai gente mantém
animação
ei nem sei o que está acontecendo o que
é isso ai gente eu não sei onde o vídeo
vai o gente é tudo montável que
diferenças gritar em triplicado